JAMES GRIME: So recently, we had
big maths news, didn't we?
We had that new prime number
that was found.
And it was the biggest prime
number ever found.
And it was big news.
And we were all quite
excited about it.
It was lots of fun.
But it got me thinking about one
of the classic proofs in
mathematics, and that is the
proof that there are
infinitely many primes.
So even though we found this
huge, 17-million-digit prime
number, it is still not the
biggest prime number of all.
Because there's infinitely
many of them.
So shall we do this
classic proof?
So I'll say before I start that
many of you may have seen
this proof before.
It goes way back.
But for those who haven't seen
it before, this is what
mathematicians consider an
elegant and a beautiful proof.
So we're going to prove
infinitely many primes.
To do that, first of
all, we're going
to assume the opposite.
So I'm going to say there are
finitely many primes.
So if there's finitely many of
them, we can write a list.
And let's do that.
And I'm going to call
them prime 1.
Don't know what it is
particularly, but let's call
it prime 1.
Prime 2, prime 3, and I'll just
go on until I get to the
last one, which I'll
call prime n.
The point I want to make,
though, is that this is a
complete list.
So that's important.
OK, the next thing
I'm going to do--
I'm going to make
a new number.
It's a whole number.
I'm going to call it Q. So let's
call it Q. And to make
this number, I'm going to
multiply all these together--
prime 1 times prime 2 times
prime 3, all the way up to the
last one there, prime n.
So there'll be only one way to
write Q. As a product of
primes, it's a unique
expression.
So there's only one way
you can write Q.
And then I'm going to add 1.
Q is either prime,
or it's not.
That's the only options
it has.
If Q is prime, then it's a new
prime that's not on this list.
That's bad.
So hopefully, it's
not a prime.
If it's not a prime, then it
is made up from primes by
multiplying primes together.
Now, those prime factors of
Q will divide Q exactly.
And here's the problem--
none of these primes on my
list divide Q exactly.
They'll divide this number
perfectly, but
not this plus 1 number.
You'll always have
1 left over.
So the prime factors are
not on this list.
So this list is not complete.
I said if there's finitely many
of them, I can have a
complete list.
You cannot.
And that's the proof
that there are
infinitely many primes.
So the definition of a prime
is that it's the building
blocks of other numbers.
So all other whole numbers
are made by
multiplying primes together.
So Q is a whole number,
and it is made by
multiplying primes together.
And in this case, the problem
is none of the primes on my
list do that trick.
They don't divide the
number exactly.
So there's primes missing.
What I've got here is a copy
of a book called "Euclid's
Elements." And this is a
textbook written by a Greek
mathematician called Euclid.
Now, Euclid lived in 300 BC.
So this textbook is
2,300 years old.
It's never been out of print.
And it's second only to the
Bible in that respect.
It's one of the most important
books in mathematics.
books in human history.
And the proof that there
are infinitely many
primes is in here.
And I checked it out earlier.
It was on page 227, which is
Book Nine, Proposition 20.
And it is right there, the
proof that there are
infinitely many primes.
There's a couple of differences
from this proof to
what I did.
One difference is my proof there
was something called a
proof by contradiction.
It's something that
mathematicians do a lot.
It's really useful.
What Euclid did was slightly
different.
He assumed that there was
a list of primes.
And he said, but you can
keep adding to it.
So you can never complete
the list, which is the
same sort of idea.
The other difference is that
this book was written in the
days before algebra.
So he didn't have algebra
to use like I did.
So all his proofs are using
straight lines and circles.
So it looks quite different, but
it's actually quite easy
to translate into
modern terms.
You see, mathematics is
the search for truth.
And this book is as true today
as it was 2,300 years ago.
We know a prime number can
only be divided by 1 and
itself, by no other factors, so
how did Euclid define it?
It's actually in here.
I was quite excited
when I found this.
So let's have a look.
In Definitions--
look here-- at the
beginning of Book
Seven, he defines terms.
Look at that.
"A prime number is that which is
measured by a unit alone."
So only units fit into
the prime number.
It was all measured with lines,
so a line with length a
prime can only fit
units into it.
You can't fit 2's and 3's and
other lengths into it.
So if we had something that
was prime length--
let's make it 7.
There we go--
then you can fit 1's into it--
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
But you wouldn't be able
to fit 2's into it.
So here's a 2.
And that would not fit
into my length 7.
Or if I tried 4's or 3's, it
wouldn't fit into my length 7.
So a prime length would only fit
units into it and itself.
And that's the definition
of primes we have today.
BRADY HARAN: So what does that
mean for that new prime number
that was found?
It's just--
JAMES GRIME: It's tiny.
That new prime number, 17
million digits long?
Tiny.
Nothing.
Insignificant.
To the whole infinity of prime
numbers, it is small fry.
BRADY HARAN: My understanding
is that prime numbers become
less frequent the
higher you go.
Their density becomes lower.
Does that mean the next prime
number is likely to be a long
way away from those
17 million digits?
JAMES GRIME: They become
more spaced out.
You are right about that.
And there's--
we're getting into other
things here.
But there are some fantastic
theories, or theorems, about
how the prime numbers are spaced
out, the density of
prime numbers.
But we are slipping into
other realms there.
BRADY HARAN: Sounds like
another video.
JAMES GRIME: It does sound
like another video.
It'll be a good one, as well.